okay so in this video we're gonna go
over some of the features of life what
do all what are some characteristics
that all life has in common so let's go
ahead and get started so when we talk
about features of life well that leads
us to discussing what is biology and you
may have heard of the definition biology
is the study of life but it's not quite
that simple we study a lot more than
just living things in biology first of
all I want to mention where we find life
life exists in a very thin layer of
earth known as the biosphere when you
look at this picture right here you know
there's no life as far as we know in the
inner core the outer core the mantle and
even when you look at the crust we find
life in a very thin layer of the crust
known as the biosphere if we kind of
highlight this area of the picture and
zoom on in when we do we can see here is
the biosphere it ranges from about 8,000
meters above sea level to about 10,000
meters below sea level that is where we
find life 8,000 meters above sea level
is about the height of Mount Everest
10,000 meters below sea level is about
the depth of the Mariana Trench the
deepest part of the ocean in that area
of Earth is where in that area of the
crust excuse me is where we find life
that area is known as the biosphere
and so what we know is today study in
life that there's over two million known
species that are alive on earth today
when you look at this picture here here
we have the six big broad kingdoms or
categories of life if something is alive
on earth it's placed in one of these six
categories so you recognize again
there's some flowers right there
symbolic of plants there's a dog right
there symbolic of the animal kingdom
there's a mushroom right there symbolic
of the fungus kingdom there is a
one-celled amoeba right there symbolic
of the Protista kingdom here are some
colorful bacteria cut in the you
bacterial kingdom and here's some other
bacteria in the archaea bacteria kingdom
but we know that there's over two
million known species and they all live
within what's called the biosphere
and when we find what we the pattern
that we see here is that if you look at
it kind of this picture of the earth and
the highlighted flashing yellow area
represents the area along the equator
where we most find life there's a pretty
simple reason why we find more life
along the equator warmer temperatures
moist environments plenty of water and
so on earth you know nice comfortable
warm environment plenty of sunlight
plenty of moisture data those are the
conditions for life here on earth
and one thing we know of when we study
biology is that there is over two
million known species I brought that up
a moment ago but what is a species
species are organisms that can create
fertile offspring here we have a drawing
of a man and a woman men and women are
different excuse me a man and women are
the same species you take a random male
and a random female and when you analyze
their DNA we find that humans completely
unrelated humans are nearly identical on
the genetic DNA level and so because
male and female DNA is almost identical
yeah they can create a human being a
baby they're the same species but when
we look at this picture our centaur is
possible if you know your Greek
mythology it's a organism that's half
human and half horse are these possible
can a human and a horse breed and
reproduce with one another I hope you
know the answer that question is no
humans and horses are different species
our DNA and horse DNA is too different
what about a chimpanzee you might know
that a chimpanzee is the closest living
relative to humans on planet Earth and
it says humans and chimps we are over
98% identical when you examine the DNA
of a human in the chimp the DNA is about
over 98% identical can we reproduce with
each other can a human and a chimpanzee
reproduce and breed and make a hybrid
baby hope you know the answers no even
though we're over 98% identical were
just not identical enough we are
different species so when you go back to
the picture of the human and the male
human and the male and the female human
the drawing a moment ago the reason that
a male and a female human can reproduce
is they're the same species their DNA is
very similar to one another
and from what we can tell is that the
oldest life on earth which are thought
to be bacteria they existed around three
and a half billion years ago in the
picture these are called stromatolites
and these are rock formations that
accumulate because of the actions of a
bacteria known as cyanobacteria and
these stromatolites are some of the
oldest evidence for life on Earth we
find and when we use radiometric dating
we find these to be about three and a
half billion years old so clearly life
is very very ancient compared to humans
humans are maybe only 150 200,000 years
old in the evolutionary course of time
so that definition biology is the study
of life does that mean that polar bears
are they a part of biology yes of course
there are living organisms plants are
plants a part of biology yes of course
they are living organisms bacteria are
bacteria part of biology study of life
of course bacteria are living organism
but here's where the definition gets a
little cloudy but a biology is the study
of life mountains are they a part of
biology you might say no because
mountains aren't alive but absolutely
mountains are very much a part of
biological studies because life inhabits
the mountain
the Sun is the Sun a part of biology
biology as the definition is the study
of life is the Sun a part of biology is
the Sun a part of biological studies you
might say no the Sun is not alive but
life depends on the Sun life is very
important for photosynthetic
photosynthesis to occur so yes the Sun
is a part of biology water so when you
look at the definition biology is the
study of life well water is not alive
but do we study water as we try to
expand our understanding of biology and
I hope you don't you see the pattern
here is yes absolutely even though water
is not alive living things inhabit the
water living things need water to drink
to survive and last one of these
examples here our molecule is a part of
biology you probably know molecules are
part of chemistry are they a part of
biology as well molecules are not alive
but yes they are a part of biology
because molecules such as the animation
in the picture that's a DNA molecule
molecules are very important in
understanding how life and cells work so
the definition of biology is the study
of life it's not always so cut-and-dry
so we look at life characteristics all
life has a few common characteristics
and if we were in class I would have you
turn to your neighbor and try to discuss
what are some of the characteristics
that all life on Earth has and then have
you of course share your thoughts but
let's go ahead and just move on with
this if you're watching at home
you
so one of the things that all life has
in common all life whether it's the
simplest form of life such as bacteria -
the most complex organisms which we like
to think are humans well all life has at
least one cell a cell is the most basic
unit of life capable of carrying on life
processes and so one thing that we've
learned over the time is that cells over
time have become specialized to perform
certain duties in the picture
you see red blood cells you might know
that the function of a red blood cell
was to carry oxygen where's another
picture here's a white blood cell you
might know the function of white blood
cells are to help fight infection help
fight off bacteria and virus invaders
here's a nerve cell a neuron which is
another name for a nerve cell you might
know that the job of the function of a
neuron a nerve cell is to send
electrical signals to and from the brain
so cells have become very specialized
over time
another characteristic for all life all
life requires energy energy is simply
defined as the ability to do work or
cause change now life when it takes in
food has the ability to break down
materials and that's what we call an
organisms metabolism well in the picture
here we're gonna have an example of
breaking down food here we have a young
lady she's about to eat a hamburger and
as she eats the hamburger it goes into
her stomach and of course once it's in
the stomach it is slowly digested and
broken down
well after exiting the stomach you can
see the the bits and pieces or what used
to be the hamburger exited the stomach
and I've now moved into the woman's
small intestines once your food moves
into the small intestines again we're
looking at metabolism the ability to
break down material and we're breaking
down the hamburger that was just eaten
so now those little black bits and
circles there and the animation those
are the remains of the hamburger they've
entered the small intestine and they
slowly get absorbed in and converted
into glucose and that G for glucose is
stored in our kidneys and so this is
again part of our metabolism and as we
go about our day our kidneys will
release glucose whenever our levels get
low and that'll give us a jolt of energy
to go about our day so again that's just
an example of how humans control our
metabolism
so the next thing I want to mention are
the two big broad categories of how life
on Earth uses energy and the first
category I want to mention are called
autotrophs and these organisms create
sugars using energy from the Sun so in
my animation sunlight is striking this
leaf and then the cells of the leaf are
creating sugars and in the process
giving off oxygen I hope you know I'm
referring to the process called photo
synthesis so examples of organisms that
are photosynthetic autotrophs include
plants the most obvious example and then
also algae let's not forget plants are
not the only organisms that do
photosynthesis they're probably just the
most common ones that we think of when
we look at these two pictures right here
we have some common flowering plants on
the bottom but the top picture is a
microscopic image of organisms called
diatoms and these are examples of algae
so again the reason i'm showing this is
just to show you that not that that
plants are not the only organisms that
do photosynthesis what about the other
category
the other category of set of organisms
that use energy on earth are called
heterotrophs and they're kind of just
the opposite
if autotrophs do photosynthesis then
heterotrophs do not they can't do
photosynthesis in fact they consume
others whenever they need energy and so
fungus and in animals are great examples
of this in the top picture we have a
wolf consuming something and in the
bottom picture we have the skeletal
remains of a cow's head and again that's
just to symbolize decomposing fungus and
bacteria that helped to decompose the
dead cow and leave behind basically just
the skull and the horns so autotrophs do
photosynthesis and capture sunlight to
make their food heterotrophs don't
heterotrophs simply consume others
all right so a third characteristic that
all life on earth possesses is the
ability to respond to the environment so
we're all faced with various examples of
a stimulus which are environmental
factors you know just watching this
YouTube video there are various stimuli
that you're being exposed to you're
being exposed to visual stimuli of the
images changing you're being exposed to
the audio the sound stimuli as I'm
talking and so we are all constantly
receiving information and which is
causing our body to change in some way
you know in the picture here at living
in Los Angeles I swear I see people
using their cell phones at the most
ridiculous of times I've been bowling
and I've watched people Bowl while
holding a cell phone in their hand well
in this picture we have someone being
careless and watch what they do they
accidentally drop a bowling ball on
their foot notice how that will start a
little chemical reaction it's gonna
start a little signal in the person's
foot and that signal is gonna travel up
the person's brain the brain is going to
receive that little pain signal and
ultimately the brain will send another
message back to the foot causing you to
jump away and probably set off a lot off
a few cuss words but touch and pressure
is a great example of a stimulus life
responds to changes in temperature
changes in sound changes in pressure
changes in the amount of oxygen life
responds to these features
and another life characteristic that all
life possesses is life has the ability
to reproduce and develop my animation
here shows a DNA molecule because that's
really what reproduction passes along
reproduction no matter how much it's
been glorified in in our society at
least reproduction simply passes genetic
material passes DNA from one generation
to the next that's really when you strip
away all of the all of the ways that sex
has been glorified in our culture that's
really all reproduction is is the
passing of genetic material from one
generation to the next well there's two
ways in reproducing here on earth two
types of reproduction one is called a
sexual and that means they can reproduce
without having sex so when you look at
these two pictures here we see the top
picture is an amoeba and the bottom
picture are bacteria these are examples
of organisms that reproduce asexually
like it says in the notes organisms that
reproduce asexually the offspring the
children the babies the offspring that
are created are genetically identical to
the parent basically asexual
reproduction creates copies or clones of
the parent examples of organisms that
can reproduce asexually there's a lot
here on earth bacteria which is sim as
shown in the bottom picture Protista
which is the top picture an amoeba is an
example of a Protista some fungus some
plants and even some animals can
reproduce asexually
in this little animation here here we
have a bacterial cell growing and now
splitting in half and becoming two
bacterial cells so bacterial art can can
literally just split themselves into two
and reproduce without the help of a
second individual
in this picture right here we have an
example of a small organism that lives
in the water called hydra hydra our eggs
are our relatives of jellyfish and you
can see this is an example of what's
called budding in the bottom right hand
area of the picture you can see a new
hydra is beginning to bud and will
eventually pop off of the original
parent so budding is a great way that
some animals can reproduce asexually
when we look at the the second type of
reproduction sexual reproduction
offspring babies offspring that are made
there a genetic mixture of two parents
here we have two beetles caught in the
middle of having sex with one another in
order to pass the genetic material on to
the next generation and so when you look
at organisms that reproduce sexually
most fungus most plants most animals fit
this description
when we look at plants here's a little
animation of a plant
the red dots inside of the plant
represent pollen here comes a bumblebee
flying around and the bumblebee we've
all seen bumblebees you know go from
plant to plant well notice how that
bumblebee had red pollen all over it at
the end and then it flew away let's
follow that bumblebee where'd it go here
comes the bumblebee it's flying look
it's got pollen all over it and as it
flies around another flower it will
leave pollen behind and that's how
plants can often reproduce sexually
pollination is the process of spreading
pollen from one flower to another that's
how plants reproduce sexually
so now that we've gone over some of the
features that all life has in common let
me ask you here's a list on the right
those very features we just discussed
let me ask you is fire alive you know if
we were in class I'd give you 30 seconds
to discuss this with your neighbor but
pause the video I'm gonna go over the
answers and to these five questions in
three two one is fire made of cells no
of course not fire can burn cells but
fire is simply a reaction of molecules
and gases number two does fire require
energy yes absolutely
some kind of combustible material is
needed for fire number three this fire
respond to the environment yes fire
behaves and responds very differently in
different altitudes in different
temperatures and different moisture
conditions number four can fire
reproduce well probably not like you're
like we're used to thinking about
reproduction but asexually yes let's say
you have a fire burnin and a spark lands
in a patch of dry grass that could start
a second fire and number five well fire
grow and develop I'm gonna say yes you
know forest fires don't begin as forest
fires a forest fire begins when some
jerk throws a cigarette butt out the
window of their car so when you look at
these the answer to this question should
be obvious is fire alive that should be
an obvious answer no even though fire
has some things in common with life I
hope we're not gonna call fire a living
a living organism well there's a lot of
objects that have a few things in common
with life that doesn't mean it's living
here's another example
so here is another example our cars
alive by the way the picture shows my
favorite car of all time a Shelby Cobra
so ask yourself yeses yes or no to these
five questions our car is alive first of
all number one our car is made from
cells well not the entire car but yes
some parts are especially if you have
leather interior
for instance the leather interior is
from the skin of a cow so yeah that's
very that part is made from cells not
the entire car but you know parts of it
number two do cars require energy at
several several several dollars per
gallon I think we all know the answer to
that question is yes number three well
cars respond to their environments
depending on the car absolutely there's
especially the the more technologically
advanced cars with traction control and
anti-lock brakes and the ability to
change and stiffen the suspension when
it encounters slippery roads so yeah
more technologically advanced cars
absolutely will respond to different
driving conditions differently number
four will a car reproduce no cars are of
course assembled number five will a car
develop no they're assembled by people
or an assembly line of machines so ask
yourself our car is alive I hope that's
an obvious answered that no just because
an inanimate object like a car has a few
things in common with life no we're not
going to call a car a living organism so
in order to be considered a living
organism it has to have all of these
so there you go there's our what is
biology notes right there go ahead and
pause the video and if you're in my
class answer these questions on a
separate sheet of paper I'd be happy to
check yourself for accurate I'd be happy
to check your answers for accuracy
either before school or after school one
day go ahead and pause the video good
luck